welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is
episode 15. for today's episode i spoke
with
isaac butterfield isaac is an australian
comedian and youtuber
he had me on his podcast about two
months ago and it was great to chat with
them
then i love talking to comedians given
how rough life has been for everyone
right comedians are great
by the way speaking of rough life we've
all recovered from covid and are fine
now
just so everyone's aware of that anyway
i invited isaac on my podcast
because he's recently had a video go
viral that makes light of the christ
church massacre
the massacre was an absolutely brutal
event where a white supremacist murdered
51 people in a mosque
in christchurch new zealand in march
2019.
i truly believe that one of the only
ways to survive the horrors and tragedy
of life
and stay sane are to joke about them
other than the carnivore diet
no but seriously if you joke about
terrible events it almost takes the
strength away from them
his joke was dark though you'll hear it
in this podcast we talk about the
backlash he's faced from the joke
and spoke about how to deal with tragedy
in an honest way
he's had a terrible form of epilepsy
that's caused him incredible suffering
so he's no stranger to the horrors life
can bring
we spoke about what jokes are off limits
if any and the proper way to deal with
pc culture
at the end of the podcast after we
stopped recording he said i'm just a guy
who rescues greyhounds
so if you haven't been introduced
welcome to isaac butterfield
also known as the buttsmarn just a man
who rescues greyhounds
[Music]
isaac butterfield welcome to my podcast
it's fine fantastic to be here mikayla i
am pumped i know you're
gravely ill but it's nice to be here i'm
not gravely ill
it's the tail end
you're the first person i've spoken to
with coronavirus i'm feeling ill just
speaking to you
coming through the screen where's my
mask this is
ghastly yeah it's it's
it wasn't ideal because well first of
all because it's coronavirus but second
of all because i put up a youtube video
like three months ago complaining about
the quarantine well it's broken
it's broken the banks of quarantine here
in australia like i know in the states
and uh
and in england at the moment it's it's
breaking everywhere but in australia
we've been pretty lucky new zealand
claims that they
haven't had any cases but uh in victoria
and australia it's just it's going
everywhere i'm in new south wales which
is uh
uh you know sort of north of uh of
victoria but
um it's coming it's coming for us we're
all gonna get caught up in it
uh i guess and uh hopefully we don't
take it
from it that's my yeah yeah mine wasn't
that bad
um it was apparently it it went rampant
in belgrade
so we got here and they're like there
are no cases
that's what they said there are no cases
which obviously wasn't true but there
are no cases
and so they opened everything up
completely
and then about four weeks later after
the elections they're like oh
just kidding there's this huge spike
which is the best way to deal with it
yeah yeah so then
we quarantined because i wasn't that
concerned about whether or not i was
going to get it but
my dad had pneumonia earlier this year i
was like okay
so we hunkered down in corn like
hardcore quarantined
and 10 days into the quarantine we all
got it
so i guess we might like i don't know if
one of the we were quarantining with
dad at the clinic so i don't know if
somebody brought it in
or if one of us got it and then didn't
show symptoms for about 10 days
but but how easy is it to get it anyway
yeah no you're right yeah
it's it must be so easy i mean how do
you catch the flu you never see it
coming asymptomatic etc etc yeah
yeah and everybody got it like every
everyone i know
here that got it
into varying to really varying degrees
like no symptoms to being quite ill
so anyway wow now hopefully i'm immune
and how's your old man dealing with it i
know as he said he had uh pneumonia
earlier
yeah he had pneumonia in january so
they did he got symptoms he got like a
mild fever and they did
a ct scan and they're like it's in his
lungs we need to
just bombard him with everything we have
so that he doesn't get one of those
cytokine storms
so he got put on like four or five
serious medications and i
think he reacted worse too than
medications than he did to the virus
but who knows maybe it was going to be
deadly i don't know
but his symptoms at the beginning were
it was like mild fever and nausea
it was like what kind of what everybody
had and then he just got bombarded with
like steroids and antivirals and
antibiotics and it was just like
that did not make him feel very good so
he's okay now like
from chronovirus but the medications
were pretty rough
i bet i was having this uh conversation
in my own mind today which is always a
sign of someone's losing it but
i was having this conversation i think
you know they always talk about the
the micro floor or the floor on your
skin i wonder what will happen
to the you know the the microbes the
germs everything that lives on your skin
from all the hand sanitizing from all
the changes in the environment it's not
being
um you know everything being sanitized
it's not being shown
or given the opportunity to to have
other
interactions with other germs and
whatnot i wonder if that will have an
impact on how we react to certain
diseases or infectious diseases in fact
moving forward i know none of us have
the answer but i just it's freaking me
out
yeah it can it can't be good
right they know people who are in yeah
sterile environments are more likely to
catch things in the future
and the amount of hand sanitizer people
are using
like they've done blood tests it's
getting into people's blood
like it's not
yeah just there's just so many things
we're not thinking about which is why i
put up that video before complaining
about the quarantine and i
i'm still anti-quarantine even after the
virus
but anyway moving away from coronavirus
i'm gonna survive i promise and so is my
dad um
i wanted to start well can you introduce
yourself to my audience just in case
anyone listening doesn't know who you
are
okay well i'm an australian comedian i'm
an australian youtuber as well and uh
i've been on the comedy scene in
australia probably for about six
to seven years now uh doing open mic
uh shows for for for a long time and
then moving on to doing uh
uh you know book shows and um and then i
decided that the best way to sort of
uh gain more traction in the comedy
world and you know
my comedy really wasn't seen as
something that you could do in australia
to become successful in australia in the
comedy scene
you have to play a certain role and that
role is the family friendly
comic you have to be able to be put on
tv at a certain time
uh of a night and that's usually about 8
30 you know so you have to really play
along those lines
and that's just not me that's just not
something that i enjoy
i've tried to write clean material it's
horrible it's gross i don't enjoy it
um but the best way
to really grow as
is not even just a comic but anyone and
i mean you've seen the exact same thing
is this through social media is through
an online presence and that's what i
started doing i started making uh
videos and i really structured it like a
business i focused on my area around me
my hometown of newcastle and new south
wales in australia
i started making videos uh making jokes
about that area
and then i grew to my home state and
then i grew to the to the home country
and then
basically branched out all over the
world so
in about a year it took me about a year
to get to 100 000 subscribers
and now i'm sitting at uh not that i'm
counting of course but uh
1.49 million uh so you know no it's
going very well and i was lucky enough
to do my
my first australian tour and then
followed it up the year after with a
with a world tour and um last year
knocked over about 96 shows in a year
and uh in six different countries and uh
i've come out with two comedy specials
now one is on amazon and one is uh just
been released on my website
anti-hero and and i'm just having fun
i'm just making content
about everything from feminism to to
diet to
cancer culture to to transgender
people to everything so i like to cover
all the different bases and uh my
youtube channel is somewhere where i
just uh
i come up with ideas and i put them out
there and hopefully people enjoy them
and i have a beard michaela and i have a
beard
so don't forget that i can see what do
you look like under the beard
uh there's not much going on um
my uh i've never really shown it off
i've been with my partner for six years
and she's never seen me without a beard
so uh it's uh it's not a good it's not a
good sign i actually have a bum chin
which no one really knows about uh so
please please cut that out of this
episode i don't want him to know it
ruins my reputation
i i don't cut anything out of these
episodes well you're gonna
my husband has like long scruff
and there was one halloween when he
shaved and i'd never seen him
shaved before and he hasn't shaved since
then it was
horrifying he's like you know and he
looks good too but i was just like whoa
whoa that is not it came in my eyes were
like this big he's like well i'm not
doing that again
it's a different person i remember
someone told me last time i shaved
because i i i was playing rugby league
at the time and i dyed my
like um i dyed my beard pink
for a breast cancer round we were having
or raising money so i
you know i bleached the entire beard it
was white or gray or whatever you want
to call it
and uh dyed pink and then shaved it off
and someone just came up to me who i
barely knew it was at the pub and he
said mate you look absolutely awful
without a beard i was like all right
probably gonna keep one fair enough
uh thank you for your input thank you
that's my face
yep this is what i was bored with you
bastard
anyway it's life
that's life yeah uh so the reason i
invited you on
i'm just gonna get into this right away
the reason i invited you on
so quickly was because i came across
a clip of you on an instagram account
from toronto
and it was like look how horrible this
man is this is his joke
and i was like oh oh so i listened to
the joke and i'm actually
going to put it in this video now
oh god no no it's going up it's going up
this australian extremist storm this
building this mosque this
room where people were saying their
prayers and going about their business
and for me the saddest thing about that
it wasn't the 52 people who were killed
it wasn't the countless others who had
their lives changed forever because
their family members were taken from
them
it was the hundreds of people that night
who couldn't make it home from
nightclubs in christchurch because all
the cabbies were dead
[Applause]
so everyone in the video um so eric
the guy who helps me out with my podcast
actually pointed this out
and said everyone in the video they go
oh
and laugh right because it is a dark
joke absolutely oh yeah
yeah and i listened to it and i thought
like holy [ __ ] that is dark
but the the crowds up like
the crowd's response is an honest
response
and then you put it up online and
this happens i guess quite frequently
with comedians
is you'll get one part of their show
taken out and posted up on twitter
and then you'll have people attack that
part of the show
and then it'll just create a mob and
it'll just
like go on from there so that's kind of
what happened to you i think in regards
to that joke
and as for this particular joke and a
lot of people pointed out how dark it
was
when i wrote it i just thought oh my god
i am the biggest piece of [ __ ]
alive that was my original reaction
because that's an
honest truth like it's a horrible joke
and
and this is what people kept saying to
me they kept saying that's so offensive
that's horrible that's mean
and i my reaction was i know
the point of the bit it is a horrible
thing to say
it's a mean thing to say about the worst
day in someone's life
when they've lost a family member or
whatever and
it's it that's comedy that's how we deal
with horrible things we joke about them
and i mean as you saw with that clip
the entire crowd laughed and stopped
to applaud an applause break uh
something that all comedians endeavoured
to find throughout a show
and that happened at
almost every show and i'm not just
saying that to make me sound good at
almost every show including
the show i did in christchurch the area
in which that horrible
atrocity where uh the australian white
white supremacists went through and
murdered uh 51 innocent people
they stopped laughed and applauded
and i am one of those people where when
i talk to my mates we all make
horrible jokes and i like to bring that
onto onto the stage
you know and it doesn't come from a
place of hate it's not hate speech
there's no uh intent to harm or hurt
people or hinder anyone's life it is
generally just there for you to laugh
and then move on from and as you said to
your point
when someone takes that clip and then
just puts it somewhere where no one
expects that you might be cooking dinner
and flicking through instagram and they
say oh my god this horrible comedian
and then you watch it then you go oh my
god this bloke's the worst bloke of the
world this is the new hitler
this is awful and um and and i get that
i understand that but if you are there
you enter the contract when you walk
inside the show of this guy's gonna say
whatever he wants to say to make you
laugh that
is the area that is the uh arena that
you're walking into it and people have
said to me mikayla they go
you can't punch down in comedy that's
such [ __ ]
i will punch you anywhere i i'll throw
i'll just throw haymakers
if i make you laugh then i've earned my
money for the evening you know that's
what you have paid for
that is why you are there you are there
to laugh at whatever it happens to be
when you're how do you come up with
these things you just like sit there and
think
so yeah i mean it's like anything it's
like any writer um
the war of art is a great book to sort
of get people around
uh how any creative thinker works i mean
just sit there and write whether it's
about
uh you know if you're thinking comically
or whether you're writing a dissertation
or a phd or whatever
you are just writing you are trying to
access
memories thoughts ideas in your mind and
then okay they become
uh they become physical they become part
of your paper or whatever you're writing
and that's what i do i mean i think of i
usually work backwards
i think of a punchline and then create a
joke around it
um and that's something i've always sort
of done i mean i think of things
when i'm in the car or when i'm at the
gym or whatever and i text myself the
punch line or the joke or the idea of
thought and then i work around that when
i get home and i sit down and i have a
whiskey and i write so you have no
limits for joke making
do you think there should be limits for
joke no none
zero it's up to the crowd if they laugh
it's funny
if i tell a joke and it bombs terribly
awful and it's a mean joke then i don't
do it again because i know it's not
funny
people keep saying oh it's not funny
[ __ ] they laughed they're for it
funny
yeah yeah it's
i mean i get where people are coming
from but my mind works differently i'm
i'm
i'm a comedian this is how i work i
don't
you know i don't curtail to certain
sensibilities
and and where do you stop like if you
offend a hundred people
out of a hundred people okay should you
not say that but what if you offend 50
people
out of that 100 or 20 or one where do
you stop where is the line
do you draw it where do you draw it
that's the i guess that's the question
that i've been pondering
and my answer that is you don't draw a
line if people laugh then you do it
yeah yeah um the other thing is
like how life is so shitty sometimes
like a lot of the time it's really
terrible
and how can you survive that
kind of how can you survive life without
poking fun at it like at a certain i
know
the way i got through having an
autoimmune disorder was
there were times when days were so awful
that i was like okay this is crossed
into the funny zone
i said when it's so bad it's funny
yeah like what do you do if if i
remember our conversation we were
talking about
uh the the enormous journey that your
your father went on when he was um
you know in a coma and and and covered
in so much medication just to help him
get through a certain situation
like what do you do there do you walk in
with an extremely sad face or do
you when he wakes up do you try and
crack a joke that's the first thing that
people try and do
because it's the only way to deal with
[ __ ] and life is
life is in many ways a tragedy and it's
a horrible situation for a lot of people
you know after that bit that i did that
that we just played
um i did a 10-minute bid on my autistic
brother one of the hardest situations
that my family has been through is to
deal with
um you know raising him and giving him a
good life
but we make fun of it because it's the
only way we know how to do it and people
say oh you can only make fun of certain
situations that affect you i think
that's rubbish i think make fun of
situations because we've all had to deal
with them
that situation that happened in in new
zealand was so horrible it affected
everyone i felt sick when i watched that
footage
and i think it's ours to make fun of as
a human race
well i agree like i said i wouldn't have
been able to
like go through the health problems i've
gone through or even this year survived
this year
i mean i think it's funny i got
coronavirus that's funny
like so it is pretty funny i mean
when i read this afternoon that that you
you and your father had coronavirus i
was like oh my [ __ ] god these bald
people
they belong jesus i know i didn't
believe it like the doctor was like his
coronavirus was like nah
i mean it would make sense with the plot
line that is 2020 but
like no it's not coronavirus and it's
like 15 days later that
all the tests came back positive and i
was like wow
wow that's funny that's kind of funny i
hope i don't die
because that would make the old youtube
video look really bad
[Music]
but that's and that's a joke that people
could make and and would you be mad at
people for doing that no because it's
obvious
you know that's that's where the humor
lies but yeah it's it's it's been an
interesting week
i tell you that um
well so the special was released on my
birthday 14th of july go me
uh 27 i know i look much younger and uh
and we put it out there and someone uh
you know three weeks later
this past sunday i think it was the
third or
second of august they just put posted it
on twitter they cut that section
uh they infringed on my copyright by the
way i was behind a pay wall how dare
they
and um that it just went super viral it
just went mad i saw it on the sunday and
i was like
oh this isn't great and then the monday
i was like oh my god
my life is over um and um
so i i i sent you and feel free to put
them up
uh if you still have them the uh the
graphic from um
from my instagram uh on the monday and
the tuesday and it was like
300 000 people went on to my instagram
on the monday and another 290 000 went
on the tuesday
and i didn't even get an extra thousand
followers this was all hate
this was all anger this was crankiness
this was this vlog is the worst person
alive
i went through and deleted all the dms
and it only lets you delete like a 100
or whatever at a time
i went through so many times i think i
must have had it
at the very minimum 45 000 dms
from angry people like just hate the
most
vile [ __ ] and i mean the one thing that
really got to me was how
um and you know i made a lot i've made a
lot of videos on misogyny and [ __ ] and
and sort of tried to break down feminist
myths and all that type of stuff but
the misogynist stuff that i got like you
just your daughter deserves to be raped
your mother
and all this attack on women it just
seems such a strange
uh way to to deal with anger for these
for these guys but anyway
um it was full on it was stressful but i
knew i i learned this from
the comedian joey diaz that the best way
to deal with uh cancel culture
is to take it head on and admit to
people why you did it
why did i do that to make people laugh
was it funny yes
is it horrible absolutely is it offense
offensive yes
um but to hide from it and i and i
refuse to apologize for it people are
saying you need to apologize just make a
quick video just saying listen i'm sorry
no that's not how we stop cancel culture
cancer culture is only and continuously
just it's bursting forward into
into the the world that is entertainment
that is twitter that is in social media
and no one is putting a stop to it and
people need to
and whether it is affecting you
personally or someone around you you
need to
go out there and say no this is not how
you deal with these situations
if you don't find isaac butterfield
funny if you think he's a horrible
person
don't watch me which obviously is
impossible because i'm amazing but
and humble as [ __ ] but
like just i i i i watch this just
fall around me and just think i just
think to myself like come on
guys this is a joke this is i know this
is a tough subject for a lot of people
but
surely this isn't something to invest
your entire life into
to to breaking me down and trying to
ruin my career thankfully i'm my own
boss so i'm not gonna fire me but
there's other people out there that
don't have that luxury yeah
yeah did you see that uh ryan reynolds
just apologized for having his wedding
on a former plantation
like in every place in the world there
is
you know there's there's something in
the closet there's something horrible
going on
you can't just run around walking on
eggshells
and i feel like everyone that's locked
down at the moment i know that a lot of
people in the states in australia
everywhere in the world really are
locked down they're still in their
houses they're finding
uh they need something to do and i was
really of the opinion that the corona
virus is going to turn this whole
progressive work culture around i really
thought
you know we'd all come together and we'd
all just be like that for a little bit
didn't it and then it just went
just fast the other way and um
you know once together everyone's
divisive everyone hates everyone and if
you're not
on the work team uh you're the enemy
and if you're not if you're on the work
team guess what you're not work enough
you need to apologize for this this and
that
and i just i don't see where it ends i
can't see where it ends and that's that
that's worrying to a lot of people not
so much to me i can poke my poke fun at
it but a lot of people
they're in a weird spot right now yeah
how did you handle
that much negative i mean that's a lot
like 45
000 dms like if i get
gone after on twitter for something or
it's general it's only really happened
for for from vegans with followings
that they've like sent all their minions
to attack me
that's pretty wearing like it's a good
like three or four days of
a lot of negativity but 45 000
dms like you got it way worse
how do you handle that mentally like
it's gotta hurt a little bit
i mean i have um i have issues with
uh you know i'm very i'm very woke
within my my youthfulness i've got
issues with anxiety and stuff and this
didn't help
but it's um it's one of those things
where i've learned
to deal with it uh you know i've i too
have made
anti-vegan videos i have anti-vegan
merch we just sold out of 500 hoodies in
a day like we
you know of just people that just hate
vegans it's hilarious particularly in
australia
big following of anti-vegan people it's
wonderful and they are
vicious for people who love life they
hate me
and you know it's it's it's sort of fun
but when it comes to things like
religion that's when it becomes really
serious people saying i know where you
live
i'm going to come for you i'm going to
kill you i'm going to kill your family
um the whole rape your daughter thing
i don't even have a daughter but me and
i must have got like
you know four or five hundred people
saying that exact line and it is
weird what a strange and horrible threat
to send to someone who you don't know i
just it's just a
i don't want to curse on your show i
know you guys are very
above board but it's just effing
horrible
to send that to another human being but
um
i think the way you deal with it is you
just don't read your dms
like i would just scroll through you
know and uh
and just to get to the bottom to press
delete all like i don't read them
like it's like the comments were there i
was reading some of the comments but
that was just to make a video about them
you know you put something out there
you're going to have so many people
um comment and say this you're a
horrible person or this you're that
and if you take that on board then you
become that person you become
you know you become uh aggressive or you
become
upset or sad or anxious or you can't
look at your phone
and i think that's a learn a lesson that
a lot of people need to learn about
social media is
yeah especially when you have a large
audience people will come after you and
they will come after you non-stop
and that's scary but um they're not
there
it's not a crowded room you're not in
any physical danger
you just have to look at it assess the
situation and find the best way
to respond and the way i responded was
uh with the video saying that i stand by
what i said
uh because it's a joke and
then just with countless memes that
people send me i just kept posting memes
and that shut everyone up because
there was this massive jump in numbers
like we said before and then it was went
back to normal
two days three days later when they find
something else to be outraged
about like ron and ryan reynolds it's
just that's how it works they just they
just move on and on and they find
someone else to [ __ ] about
and whinge about and moan about and then
that person who got hit with the outrage
train the week before just goes
thank you yes that's over yeah if you
don't apologize
like that that is a really good rule
because if you apologize
then you're admitting you did something
wrong
and then you never get forgiven so it's
not one of those things you learned when
you were little where
apology actually means you're forgiven
it's completely the opposite was with
canceled culture
it's absurd agreed and
um it's one of the big points for me was
i'm a i'm a comedian i'm not
a public official i'm not a politician
i'm not someone who heads up a big brand
i'm not coming out and saying these as
statements i'm coming out there and
saying these as jokes
now if you think that joke is somewhat
something that your racist uncle fred
would say
and you don't want to deal with it then
that's fine
if you if you enjoy that stuff then go
for it enjoy it
but freaking out and uh having this mad
panic and retweeting everything and and
carrying on i just don't think it's the
way that a rational person operates
and that's that's been my experience
dealing with non-rational
and rational people rather and it's not
the way
someone would operate in real life like
from
outside of a computer do you think you
know everyone's like
sorry i had a 16 year old boy who would
have been four foot nothing so he's
gonna fire me and bash me
michael i'm six foot eight with a beard
i'm gonna step on that tiny child but on
the internet he may as well be andre the
giant
and that's how people act you know and
it's it's sort of fun when you look at
it like that it's always good to check
out someone else's account when they
talk [ __ ] about you
i haven't heard any of your backstory
about how you got started i know you you
said you started just creating videos
just where you are and then branching
out but like
why what happened how old were you
um well i uh it was strange i always
wanted to be a comedian
since i was probably about you know uh
nine ten years old i used to watch uh
you know billy conley
uh quite a bit and really enjoyed his
stand up and watch his old tapes with my
pop
and and i started to when i was you know
i might have been uh 10 or 11 i started
hosting like the talent shows at school
and things like that and
and and then further on from that i was
debating teams and things like that and
and just went from there really and then
i got to the age of
let's say 21 and
i was diagnosed with a uh this weird
form of epilepsy
and what happens is basically i lose
control
of my head and my head gets stuck like
that for about 10 seconds
and i go blind in this eye i can still
talk i still remain conscious the entire
time
and it was just really weird it was very
strange no one really knew what it was
so i went to the doctor on my 21st
birthday and i described my symptoms to
him
and he said i don't really know but it
could be this
and i said what what's that disease that
he said you know the people who are
stuck in wheelchairs
that can't move and he made that action
so on my 21st birthday i find this out
and i'm just like oh my god what you
know this is crazy
and and i i didn't know where to go
from there i was basically
stuck in the crosshairs of death in in
my mind i thought well if i'm in a
wheelchair then i may as well be man
uh you know maybe dead and that's
obviously not
there's a lot of people who live very
very um fruitful lives
in wheelchairs and i'm not taking
anything away from that for a second but
for a young 21 year old who played sport
and uh played rugby league and all this
type of stuff who was
very much enjoying physical activity um
you know i was going out and um and
carving up dance floors at night clubs
having a good old time
and to hear that uh is a very very
strange thing so
i had that news and went home and had uh
we we had some chinese food delivered
and it was a big party at my house for
my birthday and i sort of sat there
silently just like
pondering life uh so to speak and it and
at 21 years old you don't know
you don't know [ __ ] about anything and
you just sort of think okay well
if my life's going to be over i need to
really start doing things
and start moving forward and to that
point i'd been writing stand-up
and been planning to do stand-up and
wanted to do stand-up
and then i thought well i need to do it
now or i won't have a chance to ever do
it
uh and i think it was like two or three
weeks later i did my first
open mic set five minutes and did okay
and uh then got back the next week maybe
didn't do as well went back the next
week so on and so forth and
and it was probably the first thing that
i ever really did in my life that i was
actually
really good at because i'd done things
i've always been good at certain things
like okay at stuff
but never really think and stand up is
something that i really think i'm quite
quite good at and um it was it was
it was a weird you know or a strange
uh avenue to explore because people just
go what do you mean you're doing
stand-up you're not funny you're not
that funny you know you
you're just some dude you're just some
tall weird-looking dude and i think no
well
you know i write the jokes i do this and
and then i just kept going and moving
forward and finding the best way to
uh continue to grow an audience and that
moved on to youtube and to podcasts and
to
all those uh avenues that that we're
lucky enough to have
in our time but um
you know as a kid i was just like i was
just
the funny dude i was an overweight kid
so i had to make jokes to have friends
and talk to girls otherwise i had no
chance
you know so i think that was a lucky
thing that people talk negatively about
childhood obesity but if i wasn't a fat
[ __ ]
hey what can i say
um but yeah it's um
my my story's not something outrageous
or anything like that but
it was it was good to have these these
backwards steps too
like i i um through the uh epilepsy i
developed uh
panic attacks and and ptsd from having
them in public places and
i i had my entire first tour like 50
shows or whatever it was
having continuous panic attacks on stage
just non-stop just anxiety just
high level [ __ ] and i was just in
constant fear but i got it done and
that proved to me that no matter what
the circumstance
i can do my show i can do it well and i
can
um keep everyone happy in the crowd
regardless of what's going on
up upstairs or what's happening anywhere
else in the room i can still make it
happen
and that was probably the most important
lesson i've ever had you know
uh having a mental health problem which
i have and i'm happy to
uh admit that i mean a lot of people say
no no it's not that you know
i don't have a mental health problem it
is it's a it's an illness like any other
and i'm happy enough to admit that
because it gave me the best
um perspective on life when i have
a really good day it's a really good day
you know
and it really you you really see the
brightness
of everything around you um
when you when you're feeling good when
you're getting things done when you're
achieving goals
and you know i i'm not by any means
uh where i was i was i was in a bad way
for maybe a year or two years
and i'm much much better now thankfully
through uh
a lot of different things but you know
did i enjoy that period not at all but
would i change it
no no way it's made me a much better
person it's made me a kinder person
and i think i understand the world a
little bit better because of that
wow yeah well there's i don't think i've
experienced anything as
horrible as things that affect you
mentally
particularly panic but like panic
depression anxiety
and i had like joints replaced and i
would easily take that
over the mental stuff there's like it's
just you can turn your entire world into
a
hell just from like switches in your
brain it's insane
um so that sounds very unpleasant um
i liked it yeah it was it was very
unpleasant
yeah yeah you said yeah you beat it
right yeah
sorry oh it's okay we're in you're in
australia i'm in serbia there's a bit of
a delay
we're managing it though and the
internet hasn't cut out too many times
uh you said you went in to talk to your
doctor and he's like he told you
something about ending up in a
wheelchair like
i i had a and it wasn't quite as
dramatic well
i've had some dramatic parts but i had a
doctor my like because of the arthritis
in my hands
my thumbs started to like grow at weird
angles
and i went in and i was like this is
what's up with this
and he goes oh don't worry it's bone
deformities and i was like
i'm worried that doesn't make me feel
better
thank you though like putting a name on
it just don't worry you just deformed
don't worry about it it's your fault get
out of here with your problems
what do you think i'm some type of
doctor or something yeah but
this dude and i i still respect this
doctor but he came out and he
freaked me out and um but maybe that's a
good thing
you know i wouldn't be talking to you if
i didn't hear that
i mean it's it's how you react to [ __ ]
you know
yeah i guess or people who just go
through those things
twist them around their heads so they
can cope forever
and also yeah and to that point like
you can hear some bad news like that and
shut down and never escape
and that's even worse and and i could
have easily have done that
yeah that's why you have to poke fun at
things right
and you know that's the thing if i don't
poke fun at things like that like
you know um simple things like on stage
when i talk about it i used to talk
about it on stage so that
i felt less scared of it if that makes
sense and so i'd be like hey you know uh
the lighting guy if you've got a strobe
light please refrain from using that
and um and that was just a little easy
little off-the-cuff sort of thing to
make people go okay you know this is the
thing and
and and although one lighting guy in
townsville in far north queensland he
actually hit the strobe light and i
nearly died but anyway
other than that um no i was fine uh
survived somehow um but it's
it's one of those things that you have
to make fun of the dark [ __ ] uh
just to try and make it all that lighter
and i think that's something that i've
learned this weekend
and i mean one of the questions that
i've been sort of throwing around in my
mind this week is where do i go from
here do i
with my stand up do i double down do i
keep talking and not necessarily about
that particular religion or those
particular people from those particular
countries
do i just double down and just go go
hard out i think i will
i think i have to because i feel like
i'm almost proving a point
to people that you can laugh at horrible
things and it doesn't make you a bad
person
it doesn't make you believe those things
it
just because you make a joke about
something doesn't mean you're going to
get a tattooed on your back
as the one thing you believe in this
world i think you should be able to joke
about absolutely everything and i think
i will continue to do that
yeah well it's it's weird how the times
have changed things because i remember
i don't know if this is a good example
but i can remember being in like grade
two or three
and you there's a whole bunch of
horrible jokes going around and there
were
there were holocaust jokes
like and i i think i don't think this
was particular to my school i think
that's just something
people my age joked about and i remember
kind of being uncomfortable by it but
like you didn't kids who said those
jokes didn't just get
destroyed forever like people knew they
were jokes right they're like just
because
you're saying that a doesn't make what
you're joking about
okay like that so it's just it's
strange how much we've changed because
the joke you made it's not the darkest
joke i've ever heard
like it's not it's dark but it's not the
darkest joke i've heard
uh and people have
well i guess it's weird too with social
media people have
access to you and that was never the
case like what are you gonna do get
45 000 angry letters like most of those
people don't care enough to actually
send a letter and i figure those people
like talking about
i hope your daughter gets raped do you
think that's something they've said to
multiple people given the fact that you
don't have a daughter
like is that just something they throw
out it has to be
you can't just all of a sudden say that
it's not something that someone just off
the cuff goes i'm so angry i hope your
daughter gets raped like that's not
something that happens
surely yeah you'd hope anyway
[ __ ] it i'm sorry it's just strange it's
strange how men always bring it back to
uh to women too and i was really taken
back by that i think that's one thing i
learned from that is when
when particular some dudes are angry
maybe it just goes to show intelligence
rather than coming back and arguing a
point you just go with the most heinous
thing possible that you can say and
maybe that's something that they
they should work on within themselves
but also you're not going to change
people
if you want to be a horrible person and
say something like that
whatever whatever [ __ ] like that's
just get away from me you big freak
like whatever um but yeah
it's it's um it's
it's strange how people have access to
you non-stop
and they think that you care what they
think like i just
you know i i know what the people around
me think and i know if i've overstepped
the mark
and i'll learn from that but um people
when they take things out of context and
they
they have to cancel you and they go
after sponsors like contacting my
sponsors and going
do you stand by these claims and like of
course they don't stand by those claims
they've got nothing to do with it
they're selling bloody vpns they don't
give a [ __ ]
like why why would they care
um and i guess i know why they have to
go out and say listen we don't stand by
these claims they've got to stand by the
company in line and that's fake
no i don't agree with that that's so
cowardly i don't like jesus all these
people are like oh no that guy said
something rude and i don't agree with
that like screw
off a hundred percent nobody cares
well people do care apparently but they
shouldn't and it's like
does that you think that makes you look
better anyway that's i don't
i don't there's this guy who owns a beef
jerky company in australia
booth chief original beefchief here's
the shoutout because he got messages
about how bad i was
and he told them to i'm sorry uh to use
this word again but he told them to [ __ ]
off
he said he loves isaac and i was like
yes
that's what we want someone who sticks
by like
you know if you're gonna sponsor a
comedian what do you expect something's
gonna happen
yeah yeah or they're not gonna be funny
that or something's gonna happen or
they're just not funny
so how did you have you looked into diet
i have to bring this up because i do
this all beef diet have you looked into
diet for the epilepsy
so uh the first thing i did was i went
on a keto diet
and i went on a keto diet for two and a
half years and dropped about
35 36 kilos
which um off the top of my head i don't
know how many pounds that is i think
it's like
maybe 80 90 pounds or something crazy
it's a lot yeah
yeah it was a lot and um so i ended up
at
94 kilos and i was a i was
203 centimeters tall six foot eight
so wow i was i was probably a little bit
too skinny
but i went for it and it stopped it
stopped the seizures
it was great and then and i'm on
medication now and the only reason i
went on it was because i was on the road
and i think we talked about this last
time it's so hard to stick to a strict
diet when you're on the road
particularly when you're doing shows at
night time like the only thing that's
open is fast food
that's it and unless you're going to go
to mcdonald's and eat just
burger patties which i do because i have
to uh it's tough so
yeah i went off it for a little while
but but i'm back on it now and
um yeah i'm i'm enjoying it uh i have i
went on the
all meat diet for about two and a half
three weeks
and uh and stopped uh because i just
i just just stakes just so many stakes
i was just i was 97 stake and i was just
like i can't do it
but but it's not something out of the
realm of possibility i would revisit
yeah yeah well it's not like you don't
only eat one thing because
it's the best it's the most fun diet
ever
yeah people i mean people who it helps
get really like this is great and i
think it's great too
to be fair but that's because i was like
half dead without it
if i wasn't half dead without it i
probably wouldn't be
all for it so what yeah
what do you what do you prefer do you
prefer some mouth pleasure of some
uh some french fries or chips or
whatever or do you prefer to
get out of bed every morning you know i
guess you got to weigh that up
and that makes complete sense i get that
and it was the same with the keto diet i
told everyone to get on that because i
felt better on it and i lost weight on
it and i couldn't lose weight on
anything
because i didn't understand how carbs
interact with your blood sugar i didn't
know that [ __ ]
no one teaches you that at school so
yeah i um i i think i'll probably eat
symbol
in a similar fashion probably for the
rest of my life
yeah veggies and good meat yeah
yeah that sounds good um what was i
gonna ask
oh yeah when you went off the keto diet
for that period of time did your
symptoms worsen
so i went off it for maybe a couple of
weeks and then i started having them
again
and i had a couple in public and that
sort of uh
uh worsened the the traumatic stress
issues with it and that was a shame but
you know what do you do um but i when i
so the the game that i played uh
sporting wise was uh
i'll call it rugby it's not rugby it's
very different it's rugby league but
anyway rugby
and so there's a lot of there's a lot of
head movement you know people coming
together and
um brains moving around and that would
make the seizures happen
more often than not just because of the
quick movement the change of eye
direction or whatever
so i'd have them on the field and that
was that was that was uh
one of the reasons that i went off it
was to
have to feel better as far as explosive
energy is concerned because i felt like
i lacked that a little bit when i was
on the keto diet and i still do i train
uh in an mma gym
and i feel like when i'm hitting pads
and kicking pads and stuff
i do struggle when i don't have carbs in
my system but i feel a lot better with
the keto diet so i continue with it
um but as far as longer form cardio
i feel much better when i'm on a keto
diet so it's i guess it's different
for everyone um but when i went off it
i went off it i was eating everything i
put
so much weight on because i was on the
road i was having a great time
you know i was on tour um you know i was
eating
and what my tour manager zack uh he
doesn't have a very good toy at all
one of my fondest memories of him is him
and his underpants with his big old
belly walking around with some
mcdonald's and falling over and falling
on his big ice cream
and it's just going everywhere in the
hotel room it was marvelous it was one
of the greatest things that's ever
happened to me
and you know i wouldn't have those as
memories without
just taking some time off the diet so if
it doesn't affect you too
greatly going off it i think it's a good
thing everything in moderation including
moderation
i guess uh for the
just so i don't forget for the energy if
you're having energy problems on a keto
diet is your salt intake ridiculously
high
like you might need like 10 grams a day
it's up there it's uh everything's
extremely salted
um like people see me salt and meat and
they're like are you okay
like do people not salt meat in
australia
i mean i mean salt i mean salting salt
i mean like like i'm trying to store it
in a ship as it goes over sea salt
um i'm trying to not let it rotten
but i could always uh increase it i
guess
the same with potassium and i take you
know magnesium supplements and things
like that
uh so i so i am i am uh always
keeping an eye on things like that but i
mean
salt one's always a strange one for
people to deal with i think
they see that and they freak out like
hey you're having this much salt like
it's going to raise your blood pressure
and all that type of stuff and it's
always an argument to have with people
like
um i know one of my mates who was a
nurse he said yeah it raises your blood
pressure but only for a couple of
minutes
while or you know a half an hour after
you have it it doesn't do it
forever um uh whether that's true or not
i don't know that was his uh
that was his knowledge from his i don't
know one week of dietary uh education
and university so
um i'm not too sure but to your point i
think absolutely i could probably
increase my
my salt intake and and that's probably
something i should be doing
do you do you do it as far as a
supplement or is it just
in water yeah i add it to water so um
i use well i probably
consume five grams more salt than just
salting my meat and i put like a pile of
salt on there
and it looks like people on ketogenic or
low carb
any low carb diet they secrete a lot
more sodium
uh and so a lot of the problems people
have when they go on ketogenic diets
especially with energy
is some sort of electrolyte is off and
generally it's sodium and you're big
so you probably need a lot you could at
least
test that to see if it helps with energy
because
like i said a lot of people some people
they'll say
some people lose hair when they do a
ketogenic diet
and usually that's a sodium problem too
you're you're looking you're
what are you saying oh my god
totally fine the career is gone
i know i am actually balding it's very
sad my uh
my my lip now i am my lebanese um
uh barbara he said to me is that that's
not a very good lebanese accent i'm
probably getting it done for racism
again
uh isaac your hair is receding and your
bead is going grey what is happening in
your life
so you're like 45 000 dms
i was like yeah what do you think i've
just been harassed by everyone
uh but yeah no it's uh
yeah i'm i don't know bald good on me
i've got a big beard i'll be right
i'll just comb it over
uh okay where can people find you online
i think you said at the beginning
but reiterate um if you
go to youtube and you type in i s double
a c butterfield i will be there and i'll
be waiting for you
you better come and find me you're
bastards
[Music]
you're pretty funny you're pretty funny
yeah i i have me moments um
when i get over to wherever you happen
to be in the world at the time i'll
make sure you come along to a show and
see if i can out dark myself
uh because i think that's the way it
might it may have to go
oh my god good luck i don't mean that in
a way like blackface i mean like
um like like joke why
i'm not gonna anyway let's let's see
i'll see if i need to get cancelled
again and then i might break out the
blackface
but potentially no i don't think i
should do that
maybe maybe not quite that's assuming
you're ever going to be able to
tour again can you even get into
australia right now if you're not from
australia
no i don't think so unless you're there
on a particular working visa
uh maybe like if you if you have to be
there like your
your company depends on you coming there
but you certainly have to be there and
go straight to a hotel and do 14 days or
15 days isolation
even in between states at the moment you
have to do isolation
so if you go from victoria to new south
wales you have to go straight to a hotel
i think as far as flying is concerned if
you're driving you probably get a
direction from the police
and the army which are on every border
at the moment it's pretty crazy
wow and a lot of people are yeah yeah a
lot of people are really upset with the
mask laws that have come into victoria
right now
you have to wear a mask you can only
leave the house for
one hour of activity one hour of
exercise and only one person from your
house can go out and do groceries
um so down there um it's pretty full-on
yeah that's intense that's way more
intense than north america at the moment
not that i'm there
certainly more intense than belgrade but
i feel like i really think most people
here actually
got it uh
i don't know i don't i don't want to go
back and wear masks i feel like if
you've had it already you shouldn't have
to again
but we'll see how that works so if you
end up touring in the next two years
i'll come to a show thank you um i
i wanted this today with the vaccine
if they do come out with a vaccine
anytime soon
let's say we want to go to my show or a
sporting event do you have to show your
papers that you've had the vaccine
[Music]
i have no idea do you have to get the
vaccine if you've already had the virus
do you have to get the vaccine to go
back to work do you have to get like
you know this is if you're an
anti-vaxxer out there this is like
peak you know mind explosion mode you're
like they've got us they've got the
microchips
um which you know whatever good on you
uh all the power to your sister
um but yeah it's uh it's it's
greatly concerning um but also
everyone else has got other [ __ ] going
on so take every day as you can and
or as you do and um hope i hope that
smarter people in the world the
scientists figure this out so we can all
go back to
going and seeing isaac butterfield live
and on stage it's a it's a marvelous
time for everybody bring your family
bring the kids bring the trailer it'll
be great
okay thank you thank you very much for
coming on that that was fun my pleasure
thank you very much for inviting me it
was lovely to talk again
[Music]
you